naomi osaka withdraws from the french
open
citing depression and social anxiety
now stars like serena williams billie
jean king
russell wilson and steph curry are
speaking out to support her
the tennis star shared her decision to
exit the tournament on twitter monday
just days after she made headlines for
announcing she would not be
participating in press conferences at
the french open
which began on sunday she wrote at the
time that she believed the practice was
harmful to athletes mental health
and on monday she tweeted in part quote
i think now the best thing for the
tournament the other players and my
well-being is that i withdraw so that
everyone can get back to focusing on the
tennis going on in paris
the 23 year old athlete continued
revealing that she has suffered from
long bouts of depression
since the u.s open in 2018 and has had a
really hard time coping with that
she explained that she also has social
anxiety and talking to the press
is tough for her quote i am not a
natural public speaker and get huge
waves of anxiety before i speak to the
world's media
i get really nervous and find it
stressful to always try to engage and
give you the best answers i can
naomi continued writing that she was
already feeling vulnerable and
anxious and viewed skipping press
conferences as an act of self-care
she explained that she made the
announcement that she wouldn't be doing
press preemptively
because she feels the rules are outdated
in parts and when the time is right
she says she wants to work with the tour
to discuss ways to make things better
for the players
the press and fans
and there is part of the difference in
this match osaka sees a chance
following naomi's decision to withdraw
the president of the french tennis
federation said in a statement to
journalists published by the washington
post
that they are sorry and sad for naomi
and added that while her decision to
withdraw was unfortunate
they're also wishing her the quickest
possible recovery
and they are looking forward to having
naomi in the tournament next year
ahead of her public statement the
tournament organization announced on
sunday
that naomi was fined fifteen thousand
dollars after not appearing at a press
conference at the french open
adding that the four-time grand slam
winner could face harsher penalties if
she continued to refuse to speak to the
media following her monday announcement
to withdraw
naomi received a ton of support from
some of her famous fans and fellow
athletes
serena williams who is competing in this
year's french open
addressed the news at a post-match press
conference following her round one
victory
i feel for naomi i feel like
i wish i could give her a hug because i
know what it's like like i said i've
been in those positions
we have different personalities and
people are different
not everyone is the same um i'm thick
you know other people are thin so um
everyone is different and everyone
handles things differently
so you know you just have to
let her handle it the way she wants to
in the best way that she thinks she can
tennis legend martina navratilova
tweeted that she hopes naomi will be
okay
adding quote this is about more than
doing or not doing a press conference
good luck naomi we are all pulling for
you
billie jean king a 39 grand slam winner
and tennis icon praised naomi as
incredibly brave for revealing her truth
and encouraged everyone to give her time
and space
athletes from other sports have shared
their love and support as well
nfl star russell wilson retweeted
naomi's statement
writing we are with you naomi hashtag
courage
olympic gymnast lori hernandez applauded
naomi for speaking up
tweeting that she's proud of her for
putting her foot down
adding quote your mental health matters
and should always come first
meanwhile nba star steph curry tweeted
you shouldn't ever have to make a
decision like this
but so damn impressive taking the high
road when the powers that be
don't protect their own major respect